well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here it's John over here with Halloween
right around the corner we thought we'd
start giving you some of our favorite
horrible types of things to talk about
so we're gonna do our top 5 favorite
supernatural movies today but before we
hop into this list we want to give a
quick shout out to our friends over at
shudder sponsoring this video before we
did this video we were putting together
a list of our favorite supernatural
movies then we went to shudder if they
happen also be on there too so if you
haven't heard shudder is pretty much the
ultimate streaming destination for
horror fans ranging from casual to the
die-hard aficionado and I'm sure you've
heard other guys talk about shudder
already considering how popular it's
becoming and horror in itself is a very
vast genre and on shudder you'll find
pretty much any and every variety of
horror film imaginable including tons of
films you won't find anywhere else
that's right from Supernatural movies
like we'll be discussing today to
psychological thrillers Creature
Features classics foreign films and a
whole lot more they've also got shorts
an original series along with curated
watch lists if you're looking for a more
personal touch now normally you can get
a free 7-day trial of shudder on their
website but if you use our special promo
code you'll get not 7 but a 30-day free
trial of the service that's right folks
if you're a horror aficionado hit up our
special link in the description box
enter our code and get a full month of
shutter for free just in time for
Halloween so if you're in the mood for
some bone-chilling spine-tingling horror
available all year round definitely
check out now onto our list
so number five on our list we went with
a classic and that is Hellraiser
Hellraiser quite the intense practical
effect a monic horror film that will
gross you out but you'll also love
nothing terrifies me more than demonic
stuff yeah and this is one of the few
80s classics that for me especially
really holds up and was just as shocking
to me when I first saw it as I expected
it to because some of the stuff you know
like you watch Friday the 13th might be
a little bit dated not Hellraiser in my
opinion and actually one in two are both
streaming and I like both those movies a
lot and it's a franchise which you know
not all of them but a good amount of
them are pretty good yeah there are some
some pretty decent entries in there and
the first one hey that's the classic
classic and a really unique take on hell
the idea of pleasure and agony coming
together and plus you've got the center
bites you've got pinhead and butterball
and Shatterer and all that so yeah
that's something I could relate to
definitely pleasure and agony all rolled
into one at all let's recall Greg all
right so number four on the list is not
quarantine it is wreck wreck I'm sure
you've probably seen quarantine if
you're American wreck which was a
Spanish film that inspired the movie
quarantined it's essentially just a
direct remake of that film they're
zombies I'm just gonna say that they're
zombies it's like an outbreak this see
this is where the horror fan you know
splits hairs because it's like an
outbreak movie and there are some
supernatural elements to it we wanted to
go for a variety with this list and that
is one of the best examples I think of
found footage right when it was really
taking off yeah big way because unlike
the the remake quarantine which I did
enjoy I found this one to be way more
realistic and it this one gets way more
under your skin because it just feels
and probably because I'm American and
I'm reading English subtitles to a
spanish-speaking movie it feels more
authentic to me and you don't have the
recognizable faces kind of distracting
you like adding the Hollywood vibe to it
yeah I would definitely give it credit
could see why it was brought over to the
States and it's also become a successful
franchise as well because that first
installment man is it just like a great
example of realistic found footage yet
has a supernatural element of zombie ish
outbreak style yeah so if you're in the
mood to really just get scared like this
is a good one turn the lights off and
watch this move
number three on our list you want to
take this one Kimo sighs yes I will John
Let The Right One In now this film I
wouldn't exactly say is a scary film but
because it's a vampire movie I would put
it under the category of supernatural
honestly I love vampire stories it's one
of my and probably more drawn to that
beyond like werewolves or zombies
vampires are the ones I'm most drawn to
let the right one and easily taste the
top spot for number one for me this film
just moves you has its horror elements
has some moments where it is scary but
what makes this film so special is that
there's a huge heart at the end of it
it's really kind of adorable in a weird
way it's a love story about you know a
vampire and a regular 12 year old boy
who's bullied as the whole film
progresses you fall in love with these
two children you feel the heart and soul
and it's dark yet it's beautiful at the
same time just a beautiful film ii mean
it's visually stunning and quiet takes
its time it's super subtle there it's
one of those movies that leads a lot to
just interpreting it and understanding
without being expositional which is very
hard to do and I feel these completely
succeed in this film well that's
something I really do love that we don't
get a ton of is like McCobb stories
about young love like yeah
young fairytale essence to it yeah and
that's that's just such a wonderful
atmosphere even if it is dark and macaws
are number two on our list decide to go
for another classic even further back
classic an Dracula almost almost based
on Nosferatu Oh shadow of the vampire
who has a both good movie and dragula is
also on shudder I don't know if shadow
the vampire is but a American Werewolf
in London not the same throwing Jonah
yeah this is one of my all-time favorite
vampire movies horror movies in general
looking back on it it's just so eerie
and unsettling and and it really is one
of the the textbook examples of what's
great about classic horror films well
also you know kind of going off of Let
The Right One In it's totally different
type of heart but there's a soul to that
movie you kind of care about nostril but
there's a weird twisted like absorbing
their yeah don't count or lock and all
that
it's that iconic vampire look and it's
also just got so much mood and tone and
aura and unlike Dracula not ratu's I
can't say enough about that movie and
you know even if it is from the 30s yeah
you know it still holds up today I think
and I'm not one of those people who
tries to be cool film school guy is like
I love silent films I I don't normally
enjoy watching silent films but that was
one of the few I could actually watch
and it's informed so many movies to come
from it you know nurse brought to
counter lock in and of himself is sort
of a cultural icon because of that now
even if you haven't seen the movie you
know that image you've heard the name
and if you've never seen it highly
recommended because it's it's a horror
staple for a reason alright guys so
number one on this list huh is this
gonna be obvious is it a little
predictable or a John and Greg gonna go
against the grain and give you an answer
that you wouldn't expect so we sound
like even cooler film buffs now we're
gonna go with something that's kind of
predictable but hey it's just what our
heart feels Evil Dead 2 you know I was
talking with John the other day about
how a lot of times you do a movie that
it starts off on an incredibly low
budget and sometimes when you give the
director more money for a sequel it can
sometimes ruin the film this is not the
case this is that rare thing where the
first one is awesome and then the second
one is even more amazing makes more of a
monumental landmark and a defining type
of style for a director Evil Dead 2 is
the definition of what a Sam Raimi film
is and Bruce Campbell man that's when
his personality was born like yeah he's
cool as Ashley every like part one he's
Ashley he's yeah part two he is a SH
that we have come to know that's kind of
this crazy psychotic super sarcastic
quick witty one-liners this average
relatable American Joe dealing with
demons it's spooky it's scary it's
creepy but it's also really funny it's
as a nians yeah oh and out there is
really a weird 'native and I mean if you
look at any of the sketches we've ever
made it's clear that evil that is a huge
inspiration almost anything with it
we've made that's a movie that's
endlessly rewatchable and in terms of
that franchise itself it's the perfect
middle ground between
that zany humor that you think of when
you think of Evil Dead but also scary
unsettling horror stuff ya know and of
course like the effects in that film and
those oh yeah those are just terrifying
at times it's like you're laughing and
scared at the same time which is
something that I feel like very few
directors can do
I thought drag me to hell does that
pretty well rainy man evil that too
though that that was like the defining
start of Sam Raimi finding that stuff
was it I feel like the first one was
just scary this one was like funny and
scary but it wasn't like too much funny
it's not mostly a comedy the way army of
Darkness is yeah like I said it's that
middle ground and it's it's just
beautiful beautiful beautiful gory and
imaginative so we talked about a lot of
movies trying to come up with this list
we thought about a lot of things and you
know there are obviously some movies
that didn't make it top fives not a very
huge number so a lot of horror movies
oh yeah and so these are some other
things that are also streaming on
shudder that almost made our list but
didn't for various reasons the first
honorable mention we wanted to touch on
was VHS VHS the anthology film that was
one interesting experience there are a
lot of different stories in that movie
and some of them are really good there's
only like one or two I didn't really
care for but I really feel like a solid
70 to 80% of that movie I really did
enjoy yeah definitely I mean it's you
know it's a found-footage anthology
there's a variety to it another ones
house of the devil house the devil ty
West's movies they're more subtle oh
yeah much more subtle much more slow
burn you know calling back to the old
occult movie yeah stuff like
supernatural yeah and when it goes crazy
it goes crazy for national on the way
Rosemary's Baby supernatural and
piggybacking off of that we are still
here is another movie that's streaming
that came out a couple of years ago kind
of harkening back to an older style
those sort of a cult thrillers and stuff
slow burner with some character and once
it really kicks off it kicks off Dracula
which we talked about nostril raw -
Dracula yeah that's a classic of course
classic vampire movie lucio full cheese
zombie which is a movie I was lucky
enough to see in a theater zombie versus
shark underwater and it's Italian yeah
yeah like me and me a little bit no more
me okay
Ferran amis something you can have us
the only one I haven't actually see
I need something and then let us pray is
a Scottish nappy it all takes place in a
police station with awesome that wasn't
moving I sort of stumbled upon it I
heard a couple people recommend it and
it's a really really cool movie I
thought and especially you know if
you're looking for something to stream
you know during homing season it's got
some cool ideas and it's got the gore
you're looking for it's an intense movie
and I dug it a lot there's a lot more
types of supernatural films over on
shudder but it is a sponsored video from
shudder we wanted to make sure our list
fell in line with what they categorize
as supernatural there's plenty of good
sci-fi horror there there's plenty a
good creature feature or over there I'm
sorry there's all kinds of categories on
shudder oh yeah that really make it
worth it there's a lot of great
installments on shudder that you're like
whoa I couldn't find this anywhere else
oh I first learned about shudder over a
year ago it was an app that you can
actually get connected to your Amazon
account to so we've gotten it before
back then they had a pretty good amount
of titles but now looking through it
again you're like whoa they have even
way more titles and they also have some
great guest curation right now kirk
hammett from metallica of your Metallica
fan he's got a curated list right now
streaming on shudder and there are a lot
of other curated lists based around
different topics and stuff like that
it's a really cool store yes the movies
range from you know big mainstream
titles you know your classics like
Hellraiser and stuff like that all the
way down to the really deep cuts so if
you're a passing horror fan if you're a
die-hard horror fan if ya curious at all
there's definitely something for you and
here's what I know about the horror
community especially after being so
close to jump one thing I noticed is
that they're very tight-knit they're
very passionate course they love their
horror number one thing I also noticed
and the reason I really began to hear
about shudder was because so many of
them have this streaming service so if
you really want to update your horror
movie knowledge and expand everything
you've ever thought about horror I'm
telling you guys this streaming service
is the one to get yes this is a
sponsored video but we are being 100%
careful when we tell you this streaming
service really delivers everything you'd
want it to deliver alright guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell follow us on
social media links of the description
box and of course get the shudder
streaming service and click our special
link enter our discount code for a free
30-day trial of the service don't forget
it's better than a week wink